[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem samstag
zara ist auch dabei für den sport hallo
schön und wir haben unter anderem diese
themen für sie
hinter der frontlinie der kampf der
ärzte um das leben verwundete soldaten
in der ost ukraine
pazifismus oder panzer die grünen sagen
ja zu schweren waffen für die ukraine
und 45 grad und mehr die menschen in
indien leiden unter einer rekordhitze
tag 66 des ukraine kriegs nach
einschätzung der nato stockt die
russische offensive im osten des landes
der ukrainische präsident sie lenski
spricht von wichtigen taktischen
erfolgen seines militärs doch auch die
verluste dürften schlimm sein russland
hat nach eigenen angaben fast 400 ziele
getroffen und 120 ukrainische soldaten
getötet in der ost ukraine direkt hinter
der frontlinie liegt das militärhospital
in lizenz von dort kommt die reportage
eines französischen kamerateams
christoph distel hat sie für uns
bearbeitet
der rauch vorn am horizont das ist der
krieg ukrainische soldaten die dort in
den schützengräben verletzt werden die
aber noch transportfähig sind komm ins
krankenhaus von lisicki auch dieser mann
der von schrapnell kugeln getroffen
wurde die befürchtung vielleicht stecken
noch welche im kopf ein erster check
wie heißt du sagt einen namen der mann
ist bei bewusstsein und bekommt ein ct
dann die entwarnung es ist nichts
schlimmes
15 verletzte seit dem morgen zählen die
pfleger nicht alle kim so glimpflich
davon weiß der behandelnde arzt
das artilleriefeuer zertrümmert knochen
zerreißt arterien reist fleischwunden
wir müssen viel amputieren
um weitere verletzte von der front zu
holen macht sich tatiana eine der
krankenschwestern fertig für die fahrt
schmerzmittel ein und solche gegen
blutungen vor allem die seien
lebenswichtig
meist verlieren die männer viel blut und
könnten schon allein daran sterben nicht
nur soldaten kommen an der front ums
leben seit einigen tagen trauern die
schwestern des krankenhauses um ihre
kollegin irina sie starb im
artilleriefeuer
es ist erschütternd ihre zwei kinder
sind jetzt weisen uns fällt schwer
darüber zu sprechen
ans aufgeben denkt hier trotzdem niemand
ein soldat plant schon seinen nächsten
einsatz obwohl seine fußverletzung noch
lange nicht ausgeheilt ist
da drüben sind jungs von uns gestorben
und ich lebe noch natürlich gehe ich
zurück
man kann es muthmann pflichterfüllung
oder unvernunft aber so wie der krieg
gerade läuft sehen sie zumindest im
krankenhaus von musik tanz keinen
anderen weg
fragen wir dara hassanzadeh in nico wie
bewertet die ukrainische seite die
russische offensive was hören sie dann
auch der ukrainische generalstab sagt
dass die russische offensive nicht
vorankommt doch keine 150 kilometer von
hier entfernt am südlichen
frontabschnitt gibt es heftigen
artilleriebeschuss das könnten russische
vorbereitung sein um dort die front zu
durchbrechen und um dann danach später
richtung der stadt katholischer
vorzurücken
jeden tag wird mehr von diesem land
zerstört wie ist das bei ihnen vor ort
spürbar
in den letzten tagen hatten wir nur
luftalarm und es gab keine luftangriffe
doch die getroffenen treibstofflager im
land den die wirtin sich nun aus neun
von zehn tankstellen hier ins mikro sind
geschlossen und dort wo es diesel gibt
dort sind die langen schlangen
bankgeschäften für diese eindrücke aus
nico dara hassanzadeh war dass es vielen
dank
um die verteidigungsfähigkeit der
ukraine zu erhöhen haben die amerikaner
damit begonnen ukrainische soldaten auch
in deutschland auszubilden zum beispiel
im umgang mit schweren waffen wie
haubitzen
im moment gibt es kaum hoffnung auf
schnellen frieden verschiedene szenarien
wie putins krieg enden könnte finden sie
bei zdf heute und in unserer app
cdu-chef märz plant nach
zdf-informationen eine reise in die
ukraine auch nach kiew zeitnah der
genaue termin ist nicht bekannt ob er
präsident selensky treffen wird steht
noch nicht fest den grünen verlangt
dieser krieg besondere flexibilität ab
eigentlich war die partei ja mal fest
verankert in der friedensbewegung
doch längst fordern nicht nur die
zuständigen minister vehement die
lieferung von schweren waffen in die
ukraine auf dem kleinen parteitag galt
es heute die basis bei dieser kehrtwende
mitzunehmen patricia wiedemeier und
thaddäus parade berichten der kleine
parteitag der grünen er findet in
düsseldorf statt dort wo bald gewählt
wird doch die ukraine überlagert alles
auf landtagswahlen die grünen sie haben
sich von anfang an klar und deutlich für
waffenlieferungen eingesetzt dies
widerspreche nicht dem prinzipien einer
pazifistischen partei finanziell
humanitär wirtschaftlich braucht die
ukraine unsere unterstützung aber sie
braucht sie halt auch mit waffen und
zwar auch mit schwereren waffen wir
schauen der als regierungspartei der
realität ins gesicht und reagieren auf
das was passieren wir werden immer
friedenspartei bleiben
wirtschaftsminister habeck und
außenministerin baerbock beide
zugeschaltet haben früh und vehement die
lieferung schwerer waffen gefordert auch
wenn es grünen schwer falle dabei
handeln wir und h dann zugleich und wir
haben ob wir ausreichend handeln wir
sind in der lage unsere position zu
verändern wenn sich die wirklichkeit
verändert aber das ist ja ein
qualitätsmerkmal und nichts wofür man
sich entschuldigen muss seien wir also
stolz darauf die delegierten sie folgen
ihrer spitze stimmen mehrheitlich für
waffenlieferungen für das sondervermögen
von 100 milliarden für die bundeswehr
nur dass zwei prozent ziel der nato
wurde abgelehnt verhaltene kritik von
der grünen jugend als grüne jugend sehen
das natürlich noch mal besonders
kritisch und wollen dafür auch sorgen
dass wir danach wieder zu unserem
pazifistischen standpunkt zurück kommen
dass wir uns alle nicht einfach aber ich
nehme trotzdem eine große zustimmung war
weil wir diese verantwortung tragen es
gab hier in düsseldorf große
rückendeckung für den kurs der regierung
streitereien oder gar farbbeutel wie
früher mal beim thema krieg und frieden
sie scheinen der vergangenheit
anzugehören
scharfe kritik an der ukraine politik
der bundesregierung und vor allem des
bundeskanzlers kommt heute von der csu
ein solches zögern sich verstecken sei
eines deutschen kanzlers unwürdig sagte
csu-chef söder beim kleinen parteitag in
würzburg der bundeskanzler drücke sich
davor der deutschen bevölkerung
orientierung zu geben in dieser krise
demonstrationen straßenfeste und
möglicherweise auch krawalle all das
wird an diesem ersten mai wochenende
erwartet in berlin versammelten sich
schon heute in einigen stadtteilen linke
gruppen um für mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit zu protestieren die
meisten veranstaltungen sind für morgen
angekündigt dann auch in vielen weiteren
städten
jetzt corona bevor wir gleich nach china
schauen wo sie gerade die maßnahmen
verschärfen
erst mal die aktuellen zahlen aus
deutschland
die bundesweite sieben tage incidents
ist erneut gesunken auf 717 4 das robert
koch institut registrierte binnen eines
tages 87 1298 neuinfektionen das sind 47
1781 weniger als vor einer woche
innerhalb eines tages wurden 159
todesfälle erfasst
in china sind die offiziellen zahlen
viel niedriger aber die angst ist
riesengroß vor allem in peking soll
nicht so werden wie in shanghai die 26
millionen einwohner stadt deswegen immer
mehr omikron fällen seit wochen
abgeriegelt jetzt schließen auch in der
hauptstadt die restaurants und es gibt
neue massentests aus peking berichtet
ulf röller
die behörden testen jeden bürger pekings
22 millionen einwohner hat die stadt
endlose schlangen vor den stationen im
kampf gegen das mikro virus
in den supermärkten hamsterkäufe viele
haben noch die hunger schreie aus
shanghai im gedächtnis um eine
versorgungs katastrophe zu verhindern
hat peking extra viele lebensmittel in
die hauptstadt bringen lassen
ich glaube dass peking besser in der
lage ist die lebensmittelsicherheit zu
gewährleisten
auf diese karte schaut peking sie zeigt
50 infektionsfälle für gestern jeder
einzelne hat dramatische folgen für die
menschen die dort leben und arbeiten wie
hier in davos wurde das geschäftsviertel
lahmgelegt nur die desinfektions teams
arbeiten unermüdlich hier kann man die
härte des lockt das sehen alle geschäfte
sind dicht die hochhäuser dahinter sind
leer die meisten sind im home-office man
kann hier wirklich die angst vor dem
nikon virus spüren
in der hauptstadt sind sie nervös dass
ihre 0 kopp it-strategie zusammenbricht
und panik entsteht
pekings machthaber warnen auf
gigantischen videoleinwänden die
bevölkerung jeder der sich nicht an die
regeln halte oder versuche aus der krise
gewinn zu schlagen komme ins gefängnis
der kampf gegen die pandemie ist ein
krieg ein krieg des widerstandes
ein krieg dem das partyleben in der
hauptstadt jetzt zum opfer fällt bars
und restaurants bleiben geschlossen
nachts wird es in peking still
schauen wir nach indien das ist dort
heiß ist ist eigentlich nicht
ungewöhnlich ungewöhnlich ist dass es
jetzt im april schon so heißt es seit
tagen hängt eine gefährliche hitzeglocke
über indien die städte ware glutofen
mehr als 46 grad wurden vielerorts
gemessen für die menschen ist das
lebensgefährlich zeigt morgen und
unbarmherzig brennt die sonne und unten
beginnt der müll zu kugeln immer wieder
bricht feuer aus auf delhis riesige
mülldeponie
die feuerwehr kommt nicht nach die hitze
setzt leicht entzündliche gase frei
unvorstellbar dass hier menschen leben
und arbeiten den müll nach verwertbaren
durchsuchen auch jetzt noch wir haben
angst wir atmen diese gase ein das macht
uns krank ich habe schmerzen beim atmen
das geht vielen so und wir können nicht
es ist eine qual auf den straßen dbs die
menschen ohnmächtig gegen die hitze und
manchmal auch wegen ihr seit tagen
herrschen mehr als 40 45 grad und das in
diesem engen moloch bewegen ist keine
gute idee aber es gibt welche die ihnen
bleibt nichts anderes übrig
jeder leidet er bei viralen arbeiten bei
regen kälte und auch bei dieser hitze
sonst können wir nicht überlebt
in den staaten ächzen die menschen auf
den feldern vertrocknet die ernte warum
das ist kein rätsel mehr
die temperaturen steigen hitzewellen
nehmen zu intensität dauer häufigkeit da
ist die wissenschaft klar alles das geht
zurück auf den klimawandel
klimageräte werden am straßenrand zum
kauf angeboten doch diese kühlung
braucht viel strom die netze drohen
zusammenzubrechen auch sie sind
überhitzt
so sei das andere extrem aus bei uns
nach der flutkatastrophe im vergangenen
juli an a und erft sind die
aufräumarbeiten und der wiederaufbau
noch lange nicht abgeschlossen viele
hochwasseropfer warten zusehens
ungeduldig auf unterstützung und auf
finanzielle hilfe aus erftstadt
berichtet ina kann
auch ein dreivierteljahr nach der flut
leben harald reichel und seine frau auf
einer dauerbaustelle die komplette
untere etage in ihrem haus sowie der
keller stehen immer noch im bau
man hat seine sanierung von der
versicherung hier und sie sagte ja nach
drei vier monaten ist alles klar aber
die haben so schlecht gearbeitet sie
haben leider sucht unternehmen aber
auftrag wir hatten keine ahnung die
hatten dann hier mit boden stammheimer
haben die an der wand gearbeitet und man
sieht ja was für löcher entstanden sind
der wiederaufbau in den flutgebieten
verzögert sich weil handwerker fehlen
genauso wie baumaterialien hier in
erftstadt gibt es für flutopfer wie
harald reiche kostenlose baustoffe die
von firmen gespendet wurden ein helfer
der ersten stunde ist aber schade er
leitet das hilfsprojekt und flutopfer
beim wiederaufbau zu unterstützen
gibt sehr viele häuser die noch ganz am
anfang stehen und der gutachter vor ort
war denn die häuser begutachten konnte
um zu entscheiden wie geht es weiter
über
150 freiwillige helferinnen und helfer
engagieren sich in ihrer freizeit bei
baustoff spenden nrw das durch
spendengelder finanziert wird harald
reichel ist dankbar für diese hilfe denn
obwohl er versichert ist dauerte es
teilweise monate bis er sein geld
bekommt also ideal weil ich kann jetzt
weiterarbeiten kann den leuten wenn die
handwerker kommen auch sagen was auch
ich hab's material da wir sagen bescheid
wenn ihr zeit kommt rein arbeitet für
die betroffenen ist der wiederaufbau ein
langer komplizierter weg helfer und
spenden werden in den flutgebieten noch
lange gebraucht
was läuft gut in den flutgebieten was
weniger jener von und angela app haben
in nordrhein westfalen und rheinland
pfalz mit betroffenen gesprochen
ihre reportage schon jetzt in der
mediathek und morgen hier bei uns im tv
um 18 uhr und jetzt live bei uns
was hast du nicht gesehen triumph aus
spanien zunächst real madrid ist zum 35
mal spanischer fußball meister die
königlichen besiegten espanyol barcelona
mühelos mit 4 0 die mannschaft von
trainer carlo ancelotti ist vier
spieltage vor saisonende nicht mehr
einzuholen
und wieder haben sie den meister gemacht
die königlichen von madrid hatten
leichtes spiel schon der anstoß durch
tennis-star rafael nadal war eine
besondere showeinlage vor dem
titelgewinn sechs stammspieler sind
gegen espanyol barcelona nicht auf dem
platz als der brasilianische jungstar
rodrigo zweimal zur 2 0 halbzeitführung
für die b elf von real trifft auch ein
unentschieden hätte gereicht marco
asensio macht lieber noch das 3 0 in der
55 minute bevor der eingewechselte
karina sima erhöht zum 4 0 endstand in
der 81 der 35 triumph des spanischen
rekordmeisters ist perfekt vier tage vor
dem rückspiel im halbfinale der
champions league gegen manchester city
und damit sind wir bei den ergebnissen
des drittletzten spieltages in der
fußball-bundesliga der abstiegskampf
bleibt spannend bayern münchen und
dortmund kassieren überraschende
niederlagen so sieht das im einzelnen
aus meister bayern münchen verliert in
mainz 1 2 3 dortmund unterliegt trotz
der drei holland tore bochum 3 zu 4 köln
sid deutlich 4 1 in augsburg 1 zu 1 im
abstiegsduell bielefeld gegen hertha bsc
ebenso wie stuttgart gegen wolfsburg das
abendspiel hoffenheim freiburg
ausführlich im sportstudio gestern union
berlin gegen fürth 1 1 montag noch zwei
spiele die tabelle die bayern stehen ja
schon als meister fest keine veränderung
bis zum fünften platz köln auf europa
league kurs die zweite hälfte beginnt
mit eintracht frankfurt in der
abstiegszone ist hertha bsc nach dem
remis und dem punktgewinn heute als
fünfzehnter schon fast durch vier punkte
vorsprung vor dem relegationsplatz
stuttgart und bielefeld hoffen noch
keine rettung gibt es mehr für greuther
fürth ja der drittletzte spieltag im
aktuellen sportstudio um 23 uhr zu gast
vor seinem abschied aus der bundesliga
rodica lang
und die basketballer von bayern münchen
besiegte im viertelfinal play off spiel
der europa league den titel favoriten fc
barcelona überraschend mit 59 zu 52
damit steht es in der serie best of five
2 zu 2 die münchner verteidigten
herausragend und holten schon früh einen
zweistelligen vorsprung heraus am
dienstag findet in barcelona das
entscheidende fünfte spiel um den einzug
in das finalturnier stadt noch nie
konnte ein deutsches team die runde der
letzten vier erreichen
jetzt live zurückzubauen
haben noch was für unerschrockene ein
bisschen nervenkitzel bietet diese neue
brücke in vietnam der boden ist aus glas
und besucher können wenn sie wirklich
wollen 150 meter tief in die zunge
schlucht blicken mit
632 metern ist es nach angaben der
betreiber die längste glasboden brücke
der welt das soll einen eintrag ins
guinness-buch bringen und viele
touristen
nicht überall bleibt der erste mai
trocken mehr dazu hat gleich osten
taliban wetter das heute journal gegen
viertel vor elf mit mitri sirin danke
für ihr interesse wir alle wünschen
ihnen ein schönes wochenende und sind
morgen wieder da auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter unserer satelliten
film zeigt die wolken eines höhentief
was sich heute über deutschland ein
gedreht hat es hat kräftige schauer und
gewitter gebracht und teilweise sogar
dauerregen am freundlichsten war es noch
nach osten jesus grün durchschimmert da
schien die sonne in der nacht wird es
weiter regnen asti verlagert sich
richtung süden sonst aber lockert es vor
allem im norden auf insgesamt aber immer
wieder wolken dabei aber trockenes
wetter bei tiefsten temperaturen von
zwei grad richtung vorpommern und 8 grad
im süden deutschlands morgen dann erst
einmal sonnenschein und das auch nach
südosten hin aber im tagesverlauf bilden
sich schauer und einzelne durchaus
kräftige gewitter mit starkregen möglich
sonst am sonnigsten noch an den küsten
ja und die temperaturen erreichen
höchstwerte 11 grad an der nordsee 12
grad an den alpen da sind die tiefsten
höchstwerte und 19 grad in der
niederlausitz ja und die nächsten tage
hauptsächlich im süden dann immer wieder
schauer und gewitter örtlich kann es
auch mal kräftiger ausfallen am montag
zum beispiel zwölf bis 19 grad und
mittwoch 12 bis 21 grad ein schöner ab